oui oui la sauvegarde du canal du forez
6 inventeur mais il n'est pas question
de sacrifier les jobs en forêt
le dossier du caribou fait des vagues
depuis des années au québec les
fonctionnaires les scientifiques et les
experts s'entendent la population de
l'espèce est en déclin en raison des
activités humaines notamment et ottawa
montrent maintenant le ton ce qui était
présentement n'est pas suffisant pour
protéger l'espèce québec refuse de
coopérer
le gouvernement fédéral donne donc à
québec jusqu'au 20 avril pour lui
fournir de l'information concernant la
protection du caribou si la réponse
n'est pas suffisante pour steven
guilbeault ottawa pourrait user d'un
décret encore jamais utilisée dans
l'histoire canadienne ce qui lui
permettrait de protéger certaines
portions de l'habitat du caribou boréale
l'ultimatum n'a pas tardé à faire réagir
à québec où on prépare une réponse qui
en nous des actions qu'on fait mais un
moment donné il faut voir qu'est-ce que
six ans en lien avec le milieu qu'est-ce
qu'on est en mesure de faire pour
protéger aussi l'économie de nos milieux
c'est un champ de compétence du québec
donc on a une commission indépendante
qui se penche là-dessus les
représentants de compagnies forestières
qui pourrait perdre certains territoires
de coupe si ottawa va de l'avant se font
discrets sur le débat au conseil de
l'industrie forestière du québec on
espère la mise en place de solutions
impliquant tous les acteurs de la
société et tenant compte de tous les
facteurs qui ont ou peuvent avoir un
impact sur le caribou et son habitat
pour certaines nations autochtones qui
multiplie les initiatives pour protéger
l'espèce c'est une toute autre réaction
une intervention qui est plus que
bienvenu le caribou forestier toujours
été présent dans la culture in où
certains estiment même que si la menace
du gouvernement fédéral est mise à
exécution qu'elles pourraient changer la
façon dont le québec gère ses forêts
sérieuse d'un jus de gouvernance
environnementale au québec avec un
ministère un ministre qui est à la fois
responsable de protéger le caribou
forestier et alain foix responsable de
promouvoir l'industrie forestière
les consultations publiques du québec
sur le caribou viennent d'ailleurs tout
juste de commencer ceux-ci se poursuivre
malgré l'ultimatum d'ottawa ici connaît
côté paulette radio canada québec